cut my hair
but not the beard i have a giant cold
sore here that just looks weird without
the beard i'm just gonna wait
well well um yeah intro
deep mind can predict rain better than
anyone else
the guardian is not so really truthful
about truthful language models
and an ai finishes beethoven's 10th
symphony welcome to ml news it's monday
[Music]
for centuries upon centuries millennia
upon millennia humans have shaken their
fist at the sky for the rain which they
could not predict but while the gods of
the heavens curse us with the falling
precipitation the gods of the earth
namely deep mind have now blessed us
with a system that can tell us when and
where it's going to reign deep mind has
been looking into what's called now
casting which is an area of weather
prediction that concerns just the next
one to two hours the reason being that
apparently longer term forecasting can
be done pretty accurately by sort of
modeling the global weather seeing how
stuff moves considering the physics and
blah blah blah but very short-term
predictions are not as accurate as we
would like them to be they've published
this in a paper in nature because where
else would deepmind publish and it's
actually a pretty interesting read they
cite the availability of high quality
data at least in the uk where radar data
is available at very high resolution and
the lack of current systems that work
well now instead of directly predicting
their model is a generative model and
from the paper it looks like it's sort
of a gan with a bunch of gan losses so
there is a temporal discriminator that
discriminates between real and fake i
guess temporal rollouts there is a
spatial discriminator and there are sort
of irregularity loss as well so
essentially what they do is they take a
context of 20 minutes of radar data and
from that they generate how the radar
data looks about two hours ahead and as
you can see this looks pretty good so on
the top left you have the target on the
top right you have the deepmind system
and on the bottom you have two bass
lines you can see that the deepmind
system is quite a bit more accurate and
not only is it more accurate as rated by
the metrics and also by human
climatologists or weather people i don't
know what exists in this case and while
the deepmind system is more accurate in
terms of metrics and in terms of humans
rating it deepmind also advocates for a
more impact-based metrics for example
they highlight that the prediction of
heavy precipitation at long lead times
remains difficult for all approaches and
this is one of the crucial events that
you would like to predict so the paper
advocates that maybe we should pay more
attention to the things that actually
impact such things as farming or air
travel or deciding whether or not you
can hold an event outdoors along with
the paper they do provide the data set
and also a snapshot of the trained model
there's a collab where you can download
the data set and try out the model so no
longer do you need to have a wet head
simply go here and see whether or not
it's going to rain in the next hour
the guardian has an opinion piece by
john norton that says the truth about
artificial intelligence it isn't that
honest tests of natural language
processing models show that the bigger
they are the bigger liars they are
should we be worried now isn't this
exactly what i predicted i reported on
this in last ml news i made even a
dedicated video about this benchmark
called truthful qa which is where the
authors create a data set specifically
designed to trick these language models
going as far as throwing out questions
that the language models get right and
defining the word truthful in a way that
if you answer complete garbage it counts
as truthful and therefore the smaller
models are better because they're just
worse now if you get the impression that
one should mention these things when
discussing this data set then you'd be
right and i advocated for the same thing
i said if someone gives this as an
example of how bad large language models
are and doesn't explicitly mention these
things they either don't know or they
want to deceive you well enter john
naughton who writes an entire opinion
piece about this article so given that
he writes an entire opinion piece the
possibility that he hasn't read the
paper is out the only thing that comes
even a little bit close to mentioning
the way the data set was created is this
sentence they composed questions that
some humans would answer falsely due to
a false belief or misconception really
really do you dear viewer do you feel
that is an adequate characterization of
this benchmark and do you feel that
giving only this sentence draws the
correct conclusion for people i mean
it's not wrong they did this it just
leaves out all the other stuff that you
would need to know and why does it leave
out all the other stuff because of
course john wants to make an argument
and the argument will completely fall
apart if you include this other stuff
and this is how science reporting goes
when you have a narrative already in
mind it goes from a paper that does
describe the complete process but uses
words such as truthful in very weird
ways and is already framed in a
particular manner to the twitter
announcements of the authors which hide
all of these facts in very specific
wording in somewhere down the thread to
the more popular hubs in the ai space
completely leaving away these details
and then to the mainstream media that
just picks up the talking points and
writes big articles about how bad these
things are good job everyone now if only
there were some kind of independent news
source that you could get your machine
learning news from that never ever ever
makes mistakes now where could one find
that
now moving on there is an interesting
new paper on archive that's called
stochastic training is not necessary for
generalization that argues that if you
tune full batch gradient correctly and
if you regularize correctly and all of
these kinds of things then you can
achieve the same performance with full
batch gradient descent than you can with
sgd and this casts doubt on a lot of
theoretical explanations of why neural
networks generalize so well because many
of these rely on the stochasticity of
sgd it's long been believed that the
stochasticity plays some kind of a role
in the generalization capabilities and
at least in part this paper provides
evidence that this might not be fully
the case however that being said you do
need to regularize the network so you do
need to bring some of the implicit
regularization that sgd appears to do
through stochasticity into the world of
explicit regularization if you don't
want the stochasticity in there this
appears to be true with and without data
augmentation and the paper argues that
the community has essentially just spent
a long time optimizing stochastic
optimizers and hyper parameters and
hasn't put that much effort into full
batch methods if this is of interest to
you give this paper a read
google ai releases the efficient
partitioning of road networks so this is
a method to partition road networks
because if you simply look at a road
network and try to do planning it
quickly becomes ginormous if you just
consider your own city then already
that's a pretty big graph if you really
model all the connections and then you
consider a country you consider a
continent it quickly becomes so huge
that something like a dijkstra algorithm
cannot plan efficiently anymore so what
you have to do is you have to partition
and they give the example of staten
island which is an island in new york
city and while staten island has a lot
of roads and the surrounding city has a
lot of roads the access between the city
and staten island is limited to four or
five different bridges so a smart
algorithm would sort of clump staten
island into very few nodes and then you
can essentially plan on these super
nodes until you get to staten island and
then inside staten island you can plan
locally this relies on the fact that our
road networks very often are comprised
of large interconnections between
clusters of local roads and in order to
do this they leverage random walks so
they simply start from some point on the
map and they do random walks on the map
and the idea is that if you have super
duper connected networks like inside
staten island then the random walks are
probably going to stay in that area as
they walk because the amount of
connections inside the area is just so
much larger and they're not going to
traverse very often these
interconnections between the clusters so
therefore using random walks you can
figure out what are the clusters that
are tightly connected and what are the
clusters that are only loosely connected
and therefore you can partition the
graph this is then refined using some
flow algorithms and at the end we all
get google maps thank you there is a
paper to go along with it have a read if
that is of interest to you
facebook ai research releases mini hack
a new sandbox for open-ended
reinforcement learning this is an
iteration on the nethack learning
environment which we've reported
previously is available nethack is this
game where you're in a dungeon and you
need to do certain things battle certain
things and so on and the cool thing is
that it's entirely described in kind of
an ascii way so on the left here you see
the way that players or level creators
would design levels and then add items
and certain effects to it now the netac
game is a very difficult game and if you
do reinforcement learning inside the
game there are a lot of tasks there are
a lot of things to do and there is
essentially just this one game so mini
hack is an environment where you can
create small parts of the game different
sub-levels very simple tasks to test the
individual abilities of agents so you
could for example make a mini level
where it's just about avoiding obstacles
or you could make another mini level
where it's simply about fighting
opponents so essentially it's a level
editor for the nether learning
environment pretty cool give it a try
baidu releases plato xl the world's
first 11 billion parameter pre-trained
dialogue generation model now whenever
you say the world's first you just have
to make whatever comes very specific
then you're always the world's first
like even if there were a 12 billion
parameter pre-trained dialogue
generation model plato excel would still
be the world's first 11 billion
parameter pre-trained dialogue
generation model however this is really
so far the biggest model that is
specifically made for dialogue it's
available in english and chinese and it
is specifically trained to do long
dialogue that keeps the context alive of
what's talked about also baidu says that
they will release the source code
together with the english model on
github soon
the next web news writes beethoven never
finished his 10th symphony computer
scientists just did this is a
description of how a team of computer
scientists and music scholars went about
finishing beethoven's tenth symphony so
the ninth symphony concluded with the
ode to joy they said but the tenth
symphony is unfinished there are some
scribbles by beethoven some ideas but
it's by no means a finished piece of
work so the article details how the team
went about recreating something that
beethoven might have written and this is
the important part to get right here
they do not claim that what they produce
is beethoven's tenth symphony as
beethoven would have written it they say
that this is given the ideas something
that beethoven might conceivably have
come up with now that being said there
is a lot of iterations here there's a
lot of hand engineering of course so
rather than this being fully ai
generated so i would rather call it a
computer human collaboration to uh
come up with something that plausibly
could have happened had beethoven lived
for a bit longer the article is fairly
long but it concludes with an excerpt
from what these people created
that sounds like music correct so it
seems like a a cool practical
applications of some of the techniques
the combination of ai and art is more
and more explored and it's good to see
that music is not an exception here
speaking of ai and art the smithsonian
magazine writes did peter paul rubens
really paint samsung and delilah ai
analysis renews doubts over the
authenticity of a star painting in the
london national galleries collection
right so there's this painting by a
painter i have no clue about art i'm
very sorry but apparently the painting
has been painted at some point and then
went missing for a while and then it
reappeared and there is an entire debate
about whether or not the reappeared
painting is in fact the original
painting or a fake and there is this
company called art recognition which
supposedly can give you a report about
whether or not a given painting is
actually from a given painter or not and
when this company analyzed the painting
the algorithm reported a 91.78
probability that samsung and delilah was
painted by someone other than rubens so
the company claims they have had quite a
lot of successes when they assessed
non-disputed works with the algorithm
being generally very correct in these
assessments so given this track record
the statement that this painting is
probably fake is quite a bit of a
shake-up now now now i have many
questions about this like why does this
need seven days to generate a report do
these people actually go out and collect
training data once you submit your thing
i don't know also these systems gotta be
like super duper vulnerable to something
like adversarial examples they give you
like a certificate of authenticity now
i'm gonna guess this is like a cnn and
the cnn is trained on a bunch of
paintings of that painter then you get
some sort of a closeness estimate now
are there negative samples that this is
trained at is this a one class svm i
don't know and actually found anything
in the faq about how exactly this works
apparently the entire service is just
digital and you don't actually need the
painting itself and i know a lot of
these scholars they they look at the
paint strokes themselves and the
thicknesses and x-rays and whatnot to
determine if art is uh authentic or not
now i i have no doubt that something
like this might actually work and might
actually work better than human art
experts can assess this but at the same
time there are a lot of vulnerabilities
in these systems and i also wouldn't
trust them now would i trust them more
than human experts not sure i think what
is safe to say is that simply because
this company says this is probably fake
it probably won't convince anyone in the
art world to change their minds about
this painting but interesting to know
this exists
rt writes ai-driven community
surveillance u.s cops reportedly using
invasive tool to grab suspects social
media pornhub and tinder data this
report is about a company called shadow
dragon that produces tools that scrape
social media and pull together all kinds
of information about individual people
and they sell this to law enforcement
such that essentially anything you do
across social media is neatly pulled
together and analyzed in one place this
can then be combined with other
surveillance mechanisms such as facial
recognition from surveillance and all
your data from various government
databases and it could technically be
used to do predictive policing which is
a very controversial practice where you
don't react to crime but you try to
react to pre-crime which gives it a sort
of a dystopian feeling the company's
founder says the company disagrees with
predictive policing and does not build
products with predictive capabilities or
even suggestions however also their
website praises the product for being
able to predict violence so
another question is where exactly shadow
dragon has all this data from they
themselves claim they do not intercept
any private chats and they do not access
anything that's proprietary or private
but simply scrape information from
public websites and again that is highly
disputed now even if they only collect
data from public websites it's still
quite worrisome to see that police are
using these kind of systems of course if
you are a suspect police has every
opportunity to go look at all of your
social media all across the web and
cross-reference that but this is now
being done in an automated fashion that
is available to search and yes
train predictive models on top of it now
whether or not that's a good development
i leave that up to you but a good
recommendation is that simply assume
that all of your activity online is
being carried together at some place and
just put all into one neat package so
while in a previous life you could be
one kind of person on twitter and
another kind of person on linkedin in
the future these things are going to
morph together more and more right now
it's simply for law enforcement and the
government but given that these products
seem to exist you can expect that to be
more the case in general in the future
so now you have the opportunity do you
want to behave more professionally on
twitter or do you want to just spew
random opinions around on linkedin i
know what i'm gonna do i'll also link a
more in-depth article by the intercept
about shadow dragon and its connections
to law enforcement if you're into that
all right helpful libraries we have a
lot of helpful libraries and data sets
this week like so much help on the
internet it's crazy i'm suffocating from
helpful libraries i can't labor anymore
that being said you should totally check
out hunging faces infinity which is a
docker container that you can deploy
yourself and that brings inference of
transformers down to a millisecond so if
you read more into this apparently it's
about three milliseconds for cpu based
transformers like bert and roberta and
one millisecond if you host them on gpu
now this is pretty massive it represents
about a 10x improvement over previous
attempts at speeding up these
transformers and you can deploy this on
premise fits neatly within a docker
container now infinity is in a closed
beta right now but i guess they're going
to release it at some point i don't know
there is a website but it doesn't say a
whole lot of things about it but i guess
being in beta this is bound to develop
further if you are interested click the
request trial button and see what
happens next up the text based np
enrichment tasks text base
text based
not sure which one it is i'm going to
guess text based so this is a data set
for nlp and by that i mean rather how
nlp used to be before deep learning
where every noun phrase is sort of
annotated with all the possible
cross-references that exist in the text
so for example the sentence here iranian
student protesters face expulsion would
be annotated in the following way
iranian student protesters would be
annotated at amir khabib university it
would also be annotated with against
ahmadinejad and face expulsion would be
annotated with expulsion of 54 students
expulsion by university chancellor ali
reza rahay or expulsion from amir kabir
university the goal of the dataset is to
do these annotations exhaustively which
i'm gonna guess was a lot of work but
they do end up with
5497 documents that are exhaustively
annotated with all possible links
between noun phrases in each document so
pretty cool if you're more into
old-school nlp definitely give this a
try if you are into new school nlp you
should probably learn a bit about old
school nlp next there is trocr
transformer based optical character
recognition with pre-trained models by
microsoft along with code this is a new
ocr method that uses transformers code
is available give it a try kaukoure
which is joint work of google research
and collaborators from japan's national
institute of informatics and the
university of cambridge released this
data set right here of japanese art
depicting faces so they wonder whether
or not they can teach machines to
recognize facial depictions in japanese
art and classify them into various
categories so the dataset is created
from a larger japanese art dataset by
cropping out all of the faces and then
manually labeling them the labels are
things such as the social status which
is divided into noble warrior
incarnation which is a depiction of a
god or goddess and a commoner which is i
guess the rest of us you can also train
gans on these data sets and it seems to
be just a pretty cool data set for doing
research again intersection of ai and
art this could be like a theme for today
raft is a data set of real world
annotated few shot tasks this is a data
set where both the task itself and the
examples are given in natural language
for example the task here is the data
set is a list of institutions that have
contributed papers
the goal is to classify these
institutions into one of three
categories university company or
research institute 50 labeled examples
are provided and then there are a bunch
of labeled examples but not too many
thus the name few shot tasks so this
could be pretty cool because especially
it has a lot of practical applications
if you can specify the task in natural
language and you don't need a whole lot
of examples for the model to learn a
task a lot of new possibilities in
applying nlp open up there is a paper
and a leaderboard if you want to give it
a try the next helpful thing is a data
set edgar dataset is a dataset of
financial texts edgar is a database
where all the public companies have to
send in their annual reports and edgar
corpus is a data set of that they do
provide a script with which to mine the
edgar database and they do train a set
of word vectors which for specific tasks
in finance perform much better than
standard glove word vectors so if you
ever want the corpus of a giant amount
of text that says absolutely nothing
important of any informational value
because all of these finance departments
basically just cover their own behind
there you go the next data set is pass
an imagenet replacement for
self-supervised pre-training without
humans the pitch is they have 1.4
million images 1.4 million of them are
cc by licensed and there are absolutely
zero humans in the data set not only
aren't there any depictions of humans
there are also no license plates or
other personally identifiable
information the catch is this data set
comes without labels so you cannot train
your classic computer vision image
classification task but it is supposed
to be another data set that you can use
for pre-training your models without
having to worry about there being some
personally identifiable information in
there and also without having to worry
about the licensing of the pictures that
are in the data set now are people going
to replace imagenet by this one or are
people simply going to add this data to
their imagenet data and therefore the
problems simply remain well you take a
wild guess which one of those two things
is going to happen in any case the data
set is available to download have fun
and lastly torch data by pytorch is a
very unstable prototype but it is
primitives in order to build data
loaders in order to make data loading
from various sources more effective so
if data loading is your bottleneck and
the standard data loaders don't do the
job maybe give this a try the apis might
break but you know that's life
last news for today engadget writes
samsung hopes to copy and paste the
brain to 3d chip networks essentially
their idea is to stick a bunch of
electrodes in there stimulate the
neurons see how the neurons stimulate
other neurons from this you can figure
out which neurons are connected to each
other and how strong and then you can
simply map that connection pattern onto
a neuromorphic chip now this might
actually be an interesting way of
getting a neural network with the
general connection pattern of the human
brain like the sparsity pattern or how
exactly the things are connected so it
might be a neat
architectural investigation into the
human brain however the article also
writes the move could serve as a
shortcut to artificial intelligence
systems that behave like real brains
including the flexibility to learn new
concepts and adapt to changing
conditions you might even see fully
autonomous machines with true cognition
according to the researchers
simply because you map out the
connection pattern doesn't mean at all
that you will get any sort of brain like
activity connection pattern between
neurons is only one of many many many
things that is going on in the brain
especially things like learning require
forming of new connections dynamically
strengthening connections or
strengthening synapses inhibiting
expression of genes that lead to faster
or slower reuptake of synaptic material
and all of this is simply not captured
by simply mapping out the connection
pattern forgive me but no you're
probably not going to see fully
autonomous machines with true cognition
simply because you can map the brain's
connections now these things are
supposed to run on neuromorphic chips
which means they will have some of these
additional abilities but still
highly doubtful that was it for this
week's news so much stuff happening if
you have something interesting that's
happening in your life and if it is in
any way related to machine learning let
me know we have no standards here at ml
news anything goes i'll see you next
week
[Music]
ow
it hurts